-Welcome back to the show,
Elvis Costello.
You know how to do it.
Welcome back.
-We're having quite a night
already.
-We already have, right?
-I've been on stage all week,
and I haven't heard my name
so much.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
How about that?
Madonna learned how to
play drums.
-I know, isn't that fantastic?
-Did you ever hear that?
-Pete Thomas is backstage,
and he said,
he's promised free lessons.
-Wow, there you go.
-And then we can have
the stand-off here.
I think we need to do
"Into the Groove"
and "Pump It Up."
I think that's what, yeah.
[ Cheering ]
-"Into the Groove,"
is that your Madonna...
-That's the one.
That's the one for me.
I mean,
there's so many good ones.
I mean, 50 number 1s?
-That's insane.
-I mean, I've got 600 songs
in my catalogue,
and none of them were number 1s.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
That's another record
in itself.
-Yeah, it's a record
in itself there, yeah.
-It really is.
But have you guys
ever hung out, you and Madonna?
-You know, we did, and here's --
Can I tell this?
-She's probably in her limousine
at this point, yeah.
-No, actually, her
brother-in-law, Joe Henry,
produced the record
"The River in Reverse,"
that I made with
Allen Toussaint,
a record very close to my heart.
And he said one evening,
he said,
"We're gonna do a show at
the Village Vanguard.
Do you want to come
to the show?"
And we went to
the Village Vanguard,
which is really close to
where we live here in New York,
and the table was set up
for Joe, his sister-in-law,
my wife Diana, and myself.
And we sat in the middle of
the Village Vanguard
and just enjoyed the show.
It was a fantastic
"Bright Mississippi" show.
And when the lights came up,
people looked over at the table.
There's Madonna talking
to my wife Diana and myself.
And then went --
"Nah, couldn't be."
[ Laughter ]
-"There's no way
Elvis Costello..."
-And we had a lovely evening.
We had a lovely evening.
Great music, yeah.
-That's so fun.
That's wild.
I love the Village Vanguard.
I miss that.
-It is. It's --
All the places, we've just got
to give them lots of love.
And that's what we're saying,
you know?
We're playing Pier 17
tomorrow night
here in New York City.
[ Cheering ]
-You actually have
an announcement
that you'd like to
announce tonight on the show.
-Yeah, oh. Can I tell them?
-Please tell them.
-I'm gonna play a 10-night stand
in New York City next February,
but here's the thing --
[ Cheering ]
I'm gonna print a list
of 10 songs a night
that's gonna give you the clue
to what that night's
gonna be like.
And the other 10 songs
that I might play
are a secret.
So you'll never hear
the same song twice.
It's gonna be 200 songs
over 10 nights.
-So you can go every single
night if you want to?
-You can come. We'll give you
a special price.
You want to come 10 nights?
[ Cheering ]
One price, you can get
a completely different price
if you don't want to
come at all.
[ Laughter ]
-If you don't want to
come at all,
I'll give you 20 bucks
to not come.
-Second price.
-Where is it?
Where are you performing?
-It's at the Gramercy Theater.
It's a beautiful theater.
-Oh, I love that theater.
-Played there a few years ago
with The Impostors,
The Impostors and Charlie Sexton
will be with me
tomorrow night, but also,
we've got our mate, Nick Lowe.
That's pretty great, you know?
Nick Lowe and The Straitjackets.
We're on the road now.
But -- But --
you have a different
exclusive here.
You see this here picture?
Can you see that at all?
-Yeah.
-See that?
That's me at 17,
on New Year's Day of 1972.
My friend Allan Mayes is here,
my partner from Liverpool
who asked me to join his band.
And, you know, we've been going
our different ways since then.
We played for about
a year together.
And look at this.
This is his school exercise book
he kept all these years.
It lists every show
we ever played.
-Can I see it?
-Yeah.
You can touch it.
You can put the white gloves on.
-This is real.
Look, "Rusty's Gigs."
This is your gigs.
-Yeah, gigs from 1971.
Optimistically,
there's no other date.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-And we're here tonight!
-2022!
-Now, here,
I'll tell you the story.
Allan rang me up and he said,
"You know,
it would be 50 years since we
started our partnership."
We would play everywhere
in Liverpool
where they would let us,
and a few places where
they wouldn't let us.
[ Laughter ]
Like, we played the
Catholic girls' school,
Mary Help of Christians,
known locally as
"Mary, Feed the Pigeons."
[ Laughter ]
And we were paid only
in furtive glances
and unfulfilled promises.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the contract you got?
-Actually, the ledger says
we were paid absolutely nil,
and that was between two of us.
-Wow, yeah. You split nil.
-And actually, the gig that
I played 50 years ago tonight
is in here, and I was late.
And I still got paid half.
-So this is all the gigs
and all the songs?
-All the songs, and so there's
all the songs we did
by other people.
We wrote a few of our own tunes.
"The Resurrection of Rust"
is a record --
Allan rang me up and he said,
"Do you want to get together?
It's been 50 years since
we started playing together.
Do you want to make a cassette?"
[ Laughter ]
I said...
"No.
Let's make the record
we would have made
if they'd let us
when we were 17."
-Wow.
-So I got The Impostors
and my pals, and we went in
and we made this here record.
Brand new. 50th anniversary.
And we're gonna play a song by
Nick Lowe in a little while.
-Yeah, I love "Everybody Knows
This is Nowhere."
I love that.
But I love "Maureen & Sam."
It's one of my jams.
-Oh!
-And "Surrender to the Rhythm"
is my other big jam.
-That's the one we're gonna
play tonight for you.
-You're gonna play that tonight?
-We're gonna play
"Surrender to the Rhythm."
-For me? That's amazing.
[ Applause ]
That's my jam, right there.
-In honor of Madonna,
if nothing else.
Elvis Costello, everybody!
"The Resurrection of Rust"
is out now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Elvis and Allan Mayes perform
after the break.
Stick around, everybody!